join now by the retail expert Martin
Newman who's worked in multiple
companies across the sector Martin Vey
striking in both cases they're citing
the move from physical bricks and mortar
stores to online about 5,300 jobs
potentially going and obviously the
implications for all of those families
and I'm not 100% convinced it only comes
down to your shift online and I think
the both of those businesses have been
planning cuts for a while but
nonetheless it's obviously indicative of
the difficulty they've had all the
recent ones well we've been in lockdown
and we simply haven't been spending as
much as we used to
among the closures announced by boots
some 48 boots opticians outlets are
closing is that particular part of the
market very competitive it's a massively
competitive market but it's also going
to be very interesting to see how that's
handled from our from a sort of Kumud
perspective in terms of you know how can
you continue to take people's eyes and
make them feel safe in that environment
so I think it's a combination of
competition plus few people coming into
the store and obviously social
distancing meaning they can only allow a
small number of their customers into the
store at any one time the Orang is that
boots was thought to be having a
reasonably good lockdown crisis
obviously it's a pharmacist they've had
a lot of footfall to their stores which
some of their competitors might not have
yeah it's really surprising in that
context but you know what I believe
there's I believe their sales have been
north of 40 percent down over the last
few months so despite the fact that the
most of their stores have remained open
they've obviously had a significant hit
sales and again I think a lot of that
comes down to the fact that not many
people can come into the stores at any
one time plus and it's a category that
doesn't necessarily lend itself to
online as well as others such as grocery
for example a Martin one of the John
Lewis stores that won't be reopening is
the flagship store in Birmingham's
bullring Center I mean that is not only
embarrassing for Andy Street the West
Midlands mayor who opened it when he was
at JLP
it's also a big blow for the bullring
Center itself losing an anchor tenant
like that isn't it it's terrible I mean
it's
for Birmingham as a city listing a
department store Lee joined Lewis I mean
I've been to that store a number of
times in Grand Central and it's
fantastic it's a great customer
experience and I was really really
surprised when I heard the news to tell
you the honest truth because I think out
of all of their stores has got to be
their number one store at least in terms
of the range the architect the range
architecture and the customer experience
is brilliant so very surprising now
Sharon white at JL has pointed out that
the department store sales have gone
from 40 percent online this year to more
likely 60 to 70 percent on that basis
would you expect to see John Lewis
shutting more stores over the fullness
of time well I personally think I really
do believe that the let the spike in
e-commerce sales is going to flatten
after a while prior to the pandemic it
was 20 percent of all retail sales
online currently it's obviously you know
more than double that I think it's gonna
level off at 25 percent but to the John
Lewis model and they already had 40
percent of sales online might equal to
50 percent possibly look at business
like Selfridges fantastic business they
have four stores and a brilliant online
business and maybe that's the model that
John Lewis ends up working towards over
time